on en parlait hier les collégiens ont
repris le chemin de l'école mais ce
n'est pas le cas des lycéens qui
attendent toujours le constat pour
savoir s'ils doivent reprendre les cours
ou non les lycéens sont dans l'angoissé
les lycéens se disent que vais-je faire
mais je passais le bac ne lâche pas le
passé qui va me dire si j'ai le bac ou
pas moi j'aurais été mal géré et est
aujourd'hui un lycée je me serais dit je
le dis madame chabot aussi but qu'est ce
que je dois faire
j'ai le bocce pas le bac est-ce que je
dois partir cet été en vacances ou
réviser pour septembre
tige et l'oral du bac comme au chevet
jeudi ni comme moi parce qu'il va avoir
une vitrine pour connaissent pas
connaître vous dire vous monsieur michel
mr je vous ai dans le pif regarder si
les français reprennent doucement leur
activité après presque deux mois de
paralysie les élèves quant à eux
retournent progressivement sur le chemin
de l'école mais si pour beaucoup cette
année scolaire aura profondément
perturbés l'apprentissage et la
progression dans le programme éducatif
en ce qui concerne les bacheliers ce
manque pourrait être catastrophique ce
ne sont pas moins de 730 1000 élèves qui
cette année vont se présenter au bac
2020 un diplôme impossible à mettre en
place lors d'un concours ponctuelles et
qui sera obtenue en fonction de la note
globale liée au contrôle continu des
solutions qui ne semble pas satisfaire
tout le monde
en effet certains candidats parviennent
à obtenir le bac alors que les notes de
leur année scolaire ne sont pas bonnes
si les élèves devraient obtenir les
résultats de leur bac le 7 juillet
prochain beaucoup se demandent si dans
les conditions actuelles exceptionnel
il ne serait pas plus juste de faire un
geste envers ses élèves les ai alors
selon vous faut-il supprimer le bac 2020
alors faut-il supprimer le bac 2020 jean
michel mr bah moi je trouve pas du tout
ça veut dire quoi supprimer ça veut dire
se et on la donne à tout le monde quand
on donne à tous j'aurais fait ça moi si
j'avais nommé si j'avais été là
promotion 2020 non mais ont cessé c'est
trop injuste pour ceux qui ont mis
raciale années qui ont travaillé toute
l'année et après pendant toute leur vie
excuse tout on ne fait pas d'études
supérieures dans toute leur vie on va
leur dire vous même le bac eu l'oeil
wallon l'a donné à tout le monde non aux
faucons mais ça serait une récompense
s'il ya là compte beaucoup travaillent
tant mieux pour les second pas qu'on pas
beaucoup travaillé mais faut qu'en mer
et commencer ce qu'on la nec ont
cravaché mais pendant qu'on filme en
compte continuer à travailler
ça serait trop injuste de le donner à
tout le monde ça c'est en tout cas après
votre explication
je suis alors dit il avoir un peu comme
le bac de 68 sont des races et un bac
totalement d'évaluer si on le fait sur
le contrôle coûte surfe lui sur le
contrôle continu
un postier sans puce le contrôle continu
il est discontinue le contrôle donc
c'est pas bien aucune solution n'est
bonne moi j'aimerai pas être blanc caire
en ce moment parce que je trouve que
c'est un diplôme qui ne servira à rien
honnêtement à m le bac c'est juste une
porte d'entrée pour aller en face est
vraiment des phrases de darron mais
c'est vrai le bac tu sais mon chéri il a
le bac et après tu as toutes les portes
qui vous resterez mirror et choisira ce
que tu feras en plus on n'est pas mince
temps passe ton bac d'abord non on est
en plein parcours suivant ce moment est
effectivement l'idée c'est quoi c'est
c'est d'abord un un rite de passage le
bac donc donnons encore ce rite de
passage aux gamins qui ont vécu des
moments compliqués là en ce moment moi
par mon fils a des copains qui passent
le bac bat pour eux c'est quand même
importante de quilles et ce contrôle
continu des odeurs le problème que j'ai
avec cette histoire je vais expliquer
aux téléspectateurs
c'est que là ils veulent faire le bac en
contrôle continu donc c'est sur quoi il
a dit si sur les deux premiers
trimestres de l'année terminée mais moi
je vous l'expliqué un truc c'est qu'il
ya des lycées où ils ont un tel niveau
c'est à dire que y'a un mec cac le
meilleur de la classe il peut avoir 11
en maths parce que le niveau est
complètement fou et après tous les
élèves quand ils sont dans des lycées
très très fort ils peuvent avoir et
dévoile à nous des réponses à sa série
alors c'est quoi comme en fait c'est
comme laisser par rapport aux niveaux
très une présumée du lycée en question
adacore ont lissé les notes et aborder
les lycées c'est qui qui note très dur
parce que d'un très haut niveau à corps
ouverts aux montois là on va y rajoute
un point par exemple site à 9,1 c'est le
point supérieur tu passes à dix
ah ouais je parle du bac je n'ai pas son
pouvoir l'affronter sans c'est n'importe
quoi mais ça n'a l'air les mecs c'est à
la tête du client j'aime bien lui mais
lui deux points encore à tort à 10,2
temps à 11 mai projetée pas se battre
face aux principaux geyrhalter non moi
je pense qu'il faut supprimer le bac
ben oui me dérange comme s est
complètement obsolète c'est un vieil et
n'allons kaki marché avant dans la mode
assis républicaine aujourd'hui sap
d'abord ça coûte super cher organisé
genre 2 milliards n'en a pas on n'a pas
d'argent a dépecé la joconde quoi
exactement
aujourd'hui on
on supprime le bac ensuite on gonfle
artificiellement les notes pour ceux qui
ont le bac
ceux qui veulent faire des études à
présent pas besoin de bach en fait on
est déjà inscrit dans l'est dans les
universités tout ça pour cent le bac
quant à chevron n'a pas besoin en plus
un bordel pour les parents qui ont des
enfants dans les collèges parce qu'on
peut pas mettre ses enfants quand il ya
les épreuves et tout parce que les
lycées ou des collèges sont accaparés
donc moi je pense qu'il faut supprimer
le bac et que ça marche plus du moins
cette année
cette année ou tous le sont tout autant
devant l'éternel ou six nouvelles
banques et la vie oui je suis désolé
parce que géraldine tu fais partie et je
te reproche pas du tout d'une certaine
catégorie de foncer ou le bac je me
porte vers les études supérieures tout
le monde ne pas fait pas des niches
gamins sur les moyens y en a pour qui
c'est le seul album guideront de l'orbit
d'après seront obligés de travailler si
on les familles il faut travailler pour
servir et aujourd hui tao à la base un
certain 82% 81 86 % c'est là qu'il a
lancé au mégaphone
alors je te plaît c'est vrai que 86 %
des gens qui n'ont pas le bac mais elle
a quand même 14 qui l'ont pas eh bien
oui voilà donc c'est quand même ça reste
quand même bien si pour son ministre qui
depuis l'a depuis le 21e siècle qui
n'ont eu qui n'ont que le bac son
ministre quand même donc la même réussir
mais avec bien sûr qu'on peut réussir
juste avec le bac ou mon imac n'a
vraiment histoire et ce coup de piston
pense moi je pense qu'il faut pas de
l'annuler l'épreuve faut la garder parce
que c'est quand même un truc
quitte à faire une haie prendrait cette
année tu fais quoi moi je le passe passe
moi je n'ai pas lu ces morts mais moi je
pense qu'il faut le garder
tu fais situe le dk l'année prochaine il
suffit les coins de ceux qui vont lui
préfère nommer serait tombé selon
l'évêque donc ils vont l'avoir
et on va dire thalbach mais tu vas le
col le passé pour voir si tu là vraiment
il ya des questions qu'on se pose sur le
bac
si vous trichez au bac vous pouvez faire
de la prison vrai ou faux après c'est
vrai eh ouais en cas de tricherie grave
le juge pourra vous condamnez à 9000
euros d'amande et ou trois ans de prison
et non en tout cas tu te retrouves en
prennent on attaque un gars en cellule
il dit pourquoi tu es la structure j'ai
triché au bar et tricher au bac sur
l'histoire
j'avais une antisèche dans le slip
thermiques solaires et à tricher au bac
dit l'aviron et comment ça vous ne peut
pas tricher au bac si c'est possible
c'est trop dire quoi vous en avait trop
dit ou pas assez il à votre réponse fait
supposer que vous avez des infos pas
bien là j'ai pas envie que la police et
la maréchaussée vienne me chercher ça
avait triché vous avez donné les bonnes
réponses aux autres ce soir exactement
un bravo voilà j'ai été assez sympa peut
donner ma feuille à quelqu'un qui était
en difficulté
voila voila je l embrasse d'ailleurs
thomas brisson les chéris si un élève
d'essai d'un mois avant le bac pas ça
c'est sympa comme questure et et toute
la classe obtient son diplôme vrai ou
faux faux faux faux faux faux il faut
quoi qu'il arrive vous devrez passer vos
examens 1 j'ai la réponse
quoi qu'il arrive vous devrez passer
même si vous êtes décès du patron signer
ces mêmes est mort tu dois y aller
écoute moi tout travail deux minutes tu
vas passer pour mac et pas après tout
cela ne doit pas nous faire sien c'est
bon alors le rectorat peut placer des
détecteurs de téléphone dans les salles
d'examen non mais on parle de la france
non rectorat aux etats unis le rectorat
les deux franchement vous êtes à la
pointe de la thur
c'est show johnny miller qui est
brouillon on peut pas commune c'est ça
oui on exactement bravo jean michel si
votre copie est égaré ou perdu et vous
vous avez automatiquement vers un 20 sur
20 ans à nancy sur 10 ans soit
maintenant ou la dune ans vous aurez
juste à repasser l'épreuve
ben ouais ouais ouais moi je rêvais qui
perdent maccoppi maintenant c'est en
présentant cette double peine de dire
non seulement ces eaux qui volent ont
perdu votre quad les actions nique et on
est obligé de repasser le arrête tout
l'est parce qu'il ya des petits malins
ont assuré je faisais en troll qui
rentrent pas je rendais pas ma copie et
voilà et après que j'allais voir madame
je comprends rien régine tlj avait
cartonné qui empêcha mais c'était le
contrôle que j'attendais depuis six mois
là celui là sur les
jean les probabilités là oui bah non mes
choix pas bah oui mais voilà moi bah oui
mais ouais mais bon moi ça m'arrange pas
parce que là bah oui parce que non mais
vous allez bon vent et le froid faire le
contrôle du seul banon parce que
maintenant de l'emploi du temps tout ça
moi ça me ça me décale tout va trouver
mettez moi une auto hasard mettez moi
j'ai pas de 12
wise as des trois c'est quoi la moyenne
de la classe va vous faites voilà non
mais sur moi c'est ça donc là c'est pour
ça donc à des petits malins qui font ça
et je peux vous dire cela je les ai si
vous trichez vous trichez au bac
vous ne pourrez plus passer le permis de
conduire oui je crois que non c'est faux
ah bon c'est une des légendes les plus
répondu parmi les plus répandus parmi
les lycéens moi ma mère me disais ça
aime bien si tu triches au bac tu
pourras pas passer le permis avait très
bien marché sur vous ben le problème
c'est que j'ai passé le bac à 35 ans ces
quelques années parce que j'avais déjà
le derby à la question philosophie
qu'est ce que le courage un élève a
rendu une feuille blanche en répondant
juste le courage c'est ça et a eu 20 sur
20 mais aussi parce que c'est vrai alors
ça une rumeurs est une rumeur exactement
c'est le mythe de l'élève qui aurait
répondu comme ça est inspiré d'un film
un film que j'adore le film qui
s'appelle le pion qui était sorti en
1978 un film magnifique 2ème à noël
droit merci la veille de la fin merci